Jeremy Corbyn the world is going through
a terrifying public health crisis it's
now very quickly turning into a huge
economic crisis as well if things have
been different in that general election
you'd have been the man steering us
through how would you have handled it
hope we'd have started onto it more
quickly and recognize that the only way
you can get on top of it is by knowing
how severe it is and that means testing
when Boris Johnson says as he did in his
video address that he did last night
that the ambition is to really ramp up
test and that's what they're really
doing does it irritate you given that
that's not the reality on the ground it
veritatem a great deal when nearly three
weeks ago John Ashworth and I met him to
raise these very points with him saying
the importance of getting on top of
testing and it seemed to me that the
facilities of the government to get that
testing done have simply not been
effective just in terms of what the
government has done Boris Johnson's
guarantee in people's salaries he's
protecting renters from a victor and
he's suspending rail franchises he's
borrowing huge sums to put into the
economy
are you jealous in some ways that it's
mr. Johnson who's effectively
nationalized in the economy when it was
your policy well I was condemned in
November for wanting to invest in the
economy to invest in decent pay and to
pay important workers like cleaners
properly and now what the government has
last understood that the only way we'll
get through this crisis is by investing
in all aspects of our society and our
economy so why come out of coronavirus
let's not go back to the old ways how do
we best emerge from this and also do you
think this will be the death of
capitalism as we know it well the free
market cannot answer coronavirus the
only way that we can maintain living
standards and regenerate the economy
after coronavirus is by a process of
public investment I guess the question
is do you worry that for the Labor Party
if the conservative party through
necessity rather than ideology has to
become a big spending big welfare state
party where does labour find its
identity not sure the Conservative Party
is a leopard that's changed all its
spots yes they have recognized the need
for investment in our society they've
recognized you cannot go on underfunding
public services and not pay a price but
I don't believe their ideology has
fundamentally changed any more than our
ideology is going to change because we
believe in spending for the good of all
given the strain that the government is
now under in terms of dealing with
coronavirus do you think that this is
the moment that the government should
just press pause on those brexit talks
and just extend the transition while
we're moving through this crisis I think
we should concentrate totally now on
dealing with the issues surrounding
coronavirus just to be clear you you you
think it's we should just Park it or do
you think we should just say we're not
going to do brexit this year we've got
something bigger market until we get
through with coronavirus this isn't the
time to get into some debate on this the
issue has to be dealing with coronavirus
and the need for a global response on it
the labor parties have merged from your
leadership as a very different party to
what it was when you became leader
it now has a socialist policy consensus
but the country in both elections
embrace conservatism so you won the
argument within the labour party but not
with the wider public well I don't think
you can say we lost the argument I think
we have put forward the arguments and in
many ways what is now happening
overgrown a virus proves the validity of
the arguments we put forward you also
must acknowledge that you now have fewer
seats in parliament than you did when
you became leader it's bittersweet and a
way for you presumably that you've
managed to transform the party and yet
in terms of seats in terms of the wider
public it's not quite of course I was
desperately disappointed at the result
of the general election des really
disappointed its tanker own a virus to
wake everybody up to the value of what
we were saying then
and I think the future of the socialist
values that we put forward the future of
our party and its principles in the
community are as relevant and strong if
not stronger than ever let's move to
what it was like being leader for
decades you were a backbench
campaigner I've always been a campaign
campaigning politician always will be
what was it like to have to move from
that to becoming the Labour leader first
time I ever sat or spoke from the front
bench was when I became leader of the
party and I've never forgotten that
first Prime Minister's question time I
arrived there and the place was
absolutely RAM packed and all eyes were
on us and so I decided to ask questions
on behalf of the people that had sent
them in to me because I think politics
has to change and what I've learnt the
most is that you learn a lot actually
listening to people in in communities
all over the country there are a
thousand frustrations every day at being
leader of the party and there's never
enough hours in the day to achieve the
things that you want to do a thousand
frustrations every day what were your
biggest frustrations the difficulty of
getting getting a message across and
always having to balance whether you
respond to the immediate or try to raise
the sights into what you're trying to
achieve in the long term and dealing
with large personalities that the world
is full of what's been your deepest
regret not winning the two general
elections how was it when you lost that
second election was it crushing to be
defeated on that and on that scale it
must have been off of course it was a a
moment one's never going to forget but
you don't give up on your principles you
don't give up on your ideas you don't
give up on your determination and I will
be campaigning forever do you feel that
you have been disproportionately
unfairly treated by the media and the
stuff that was written about my family
about me about my friends about my
community absolutely disgusting just
disgust
it wasn't an attempt at reporting it
wasn't an attempt at political debate it
was just assassination from day one and
that is something that is damaging for
our democracy one thing I did want to
ask you about was the sort of personal
issue you must have had around and
services and criticism about your
handling of it would you put that as
your well most difficult issue also
personally because the racism Arsenal
racism divides that's what it's intended
to do and anti-semitism is a uniquely
vile form of racism that has to be
challenged and contended with and that
I've done I was there on the day of
their faith race and faith manifesto
launched and I remember you looked I
thought quite upset you'd been shouted
at you've been called a racist as you
came into the building that must have
been hard it is totally unfair and it is
totally wrong and as far as I'm
concerned I've spent my life opposing
racism in any form and I will spend the
rest of my life opposing racism in any
form in our society pmq is the final
ward you joke with the prime minister
you said you sound like you were right
in my victory and then you said I'm
still here my voice will not be stilled
what form does that take for you it
means that I'll be there speaking out on
things that I believe in whether it's
easy or not I do think it's the job of
democratically elected politicians to be
prepared to step outside the comfort
zone and speak up on these issues
because if we don't speak up for them
nobody else is going to do so okay thank
you very much thank you